Elaine is with us in Louisiana
hi Elaine welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show hi thank you for taking my call I
need your help in what I need to do I'm
going through a divorce and my husband
has filed chapter 13 bankruptcy and I'm
in the home I have a milk it some equity
in the home but not nearly enough to pay
the bankruptcy and I don't know what to
do in a community property state
I believe his creditors will eventually
come after me and I can't afford I can't
afford it if he completes the chapter 13
they will not come after you the chapter
13 is a payment plan that lasts five
years and at the end of the payment plan
the bankruptcy is concluded and they
have received all that they're going to
receive if he fails and does not
complete the thirteen which happens
sadly a large percentage of the time
then you could be left holding the bag
because he would convert to a chapter 7
wiping out all of his obligation leaving
you on the hook for all of it are you
signed up with a bunch of these
creditors no none of them okay and when
will the divorce be final uh you know
few months why so long just a minor
child and you have to wait a year okay
all right and when will he file has he
already filed he already did he's
already filed and he has a enormous note
that he paid for every Margaret that I
don't if he can keep making that note
until if he can keep making that note
until the divorce is final you're no
longer on the hook what do you well when
you're not married to him community
property does not apply you're not on
the hook for his debts anymore now any
debts that have your name on them that
you put your name on you're on the hook
for those
right if you got your name on all this
death that he's got no I do not how my
dad has your name on it
none of it you don't have any debt in
your name anywhere only the home okay
and but his attorney told him that
because he had a business and my name
was on that business not anymore though
because you're divorced will be divorced
yes we're saying that because of what
happened in the past during the time
that it was made
we were community I don't think that's
right I'm not an attorney you need to
talk to your attorney to be sure because
Louisiana does have some unusual laws in
this regard but I did talk to my
attorney and they she just said that
they could possibly possibly come after
me I don't I don't think they can I
don't think they will I disagree I
really I think your attorneys acting
that your divorce attorneys act like a
bankruptcy attorney here I you know
again you don't have your name on it and
you're not married to the guy and right
now it's in bankruptcy as long as he's
in Chapter thirteen you're completely
protected you not to worry about it it's
the only time we worry about this is if
the chapter thirteen fails right which I
don't I don't see it you don't think
he's gonna make it because his notes -
hi another team way way way too high
okay all right I mean I just want him to
hang on to the divorce is final and then
you've got real grounds to say I'm not
paying anything as his I mean you're no
more liable for his debts than you would
be mine at that point right and III
think it's a real stretch to say your
name was on the business he ran up all
the debt and he went into a chapter 13
and after a divorce that they're going
to come back based on the fact that you
had your name on a few of the documents
at the business you don't have your name
on anything at the business now right no
well the bank
was only thing my name were gone yeah
yeah I don't think I don't think there's
a chance they can get you on this again
I'm practicing law here which is
dangerous okay I'm not a lawyer but I
really I if I were in your shoes I would
hire an attorney that had big long fangs
and would scratch somebody's eyes out if
they came after you I just don't think
it's going to happen
I really really it's not logical it does
it doesn't flow with standard legal
practice and plus you don't have
anything it's not like you're sitting
there on a million dollars it's not like
you've got a target so if you're a big
target I guess we'd worry about it even
more so let's get the let's make sure
Bubba stays alive until the divorce is
final that's a big thing he doesn't he
did that bankruptcy stays upright until
then that that's a big deal right there
make sure your name's not currently on
anything having to do with that business
so that it's all finalized at the
divorce and then you worry about the
house and you worry about your bills and
let's get you moving on all of that